[Laughter]
prince william is a father of three and
he may want to keep it that way
[Laughter]
the duke and duchess of cambridge
traveled to lancashire england on
thursday meeting with staff and families
at a local hospital
at one point in the visit kate held a
baby girl in her arms while the crowd
was loving this precious moment william
felt compelled to make one thing clear
[Laughter]
william may not have baby fever but this
fur baby a therapy dog named alfie was
certainly taken with him during the
visit
this event comes two years after kate
seemingly confirmed williams feelings
about children during a public
appearance in january 2020 it was
reported kate was asked about a
potential baby number four by a fan in
the crowd and her response was quote i
don't think william wants anymore the
royal couple shares three children
prince george princess charlotte and
prince louis kate celebrated her 40th
birthday this month we are seeing work
that she's put 10 years into now coming
to fruition and it's work that really is
making a difference according to et's
royal expert katie nichol william and
kate's family bring a sense of stability
to buckingham palace
she's very much respected
loved and admired within the family and
i think at a time of uncertainty and
turbulence and and great personal
distress the queen having kate and
william as as solid and as happy as they
are with a trio of lovely children and
is a source of great joy and happiness
for the queen and i think she's very
much in need of that happiness at the
moment it's not been an easy time for
her it's not been an easy start to the
new year i think what we're seeing in
kate
the work that she has done her work in
the early years which has very much
become the cornerstone of her public
work is that she has
laid down the foundations for her future
role i think we will see her do more
work with young people more work in the
area of mental health certainly more
work into that early years campaign
which was slightly um slightly pushed on
pause because of the cove pandemic and i
think we will certainly see her step up
to the plate to support the queen as she
has done very happily always with a
smile on her face always with enthusiasm
[Music]